hey baysiders dexter darden here and i
play devonta on save by the bell i'm
here today to take you through all the
easter eggs and throwbacks for season
one of saved by the bell
welcome back to bayside high school it
may look different since the last time
we saw the gang walk in the halls but
some things never change and we have
proof did you catch every easter egg and
throwback from season one of the peacock
original series saved by the bell
keep your eyes peeled you won't want to
miss these we all know slater jesse zach
kelly and lisa are back but what about
some of our other favorites
you may remember max the magician turns
out he's been working at the max for
quite some time now and is still up to
his old tricks
literally damn i love magic
did you catch who else is still around
after all these years it's simple math
really mr dewey the gang's math teacher
from back in the day is still talking
numbers at bay style
but of course those weren't the only
familiar faces troy furlman appears in
the 10th episode as a man in line at
city hall
troy played not one but two completely
different characters in the original
series scud and ox ah
the 90s
speaking of the 90s remember way back in
season four when screech had a chess
rival with a russian exchange student
from valley well he made his way back
from the valley and on to episode three
of the new series
in this time he brought roses not a
rivalry
here's another fun cameo these two
members of tommen's band
those are the original composers for
save by the bell
scott gail and rich eames rock and roll
okay how many of those cameos did you
guys know already quit sucking up now
let's take our attention to the sets
sure there are some new hanging spots
for the bayside gang but these three
places have stood the test of time
obviously you recognize the original
hallway from the classic series right
but did you notice the glow up
i mean you can see more than one angle
then we have the principal's office
the name on the door may have changed
from belding to todman but other than
that it's basically the same
and of course the max the hippest spot
in town to grab a bite every single day
isn't that expensive yeah
everything at the max will look familiar
the shapes on the wall the neon sign the
payphone whatever that is and the
starburst chandelier above the door
hasn't gone anywhere even the wait
staff's uniforms are the same hey if it
ain't broke don't fix it
in episode 8 the todd capsule you may
notice something familiar in zack's
bedroom
ah we see you kelly and the frame is a
picture much like the larger version he
had in his room back in the day just a
little more sophisticated
and appropriate
kelly kapowski loves volleyball
windsurfing and soon me
by the way zack's not the only one who
kept items that nod back to their glory
days
slater's office has his wrestling
singlet framed and hanging on the wall
surprising absolutely no
now let's get into the nitty gritty the
true easter eggs first up in the pilot
episode keep your eyes wide open for
everything in zack's office like his
bayside diploma the date listed is the
actual date the graduation episode aired
if all that isn't meta enough for you
each episode title is either the same or
a play on an episode from the original
series episode 2 clubs and clicks has
the same name of an episode from when
the show was called good morning miss
bliss
same with the new season finale showdown
that was the sixth episode of the og
series
the bayside triangle third episode of
the new series season 4 episode 5 of the
original the fabulous birchwood boys is
a play on the classic episode of the
fabulous belding boys rent a mom meet
brenna pop in this universe the teen
line is still a thing in 2020
so of course it's a house party the todd
capsule is a play on the time capsule an
episode from season four all in the hall
more like all in the mall or wait is it
the other way around there are even more
grand odes to be original for instance
it wouldn't be saved by the bell without
dancing
this was such an iconic moment from the
classic series that you know we had to
run it back
you may have missed it but in the pilot
mac asked
do you
want to go to the max and have a dance
contest about it which is a nod back to
the dance contest in an episode of the
original series dancing at the max
another reference to this episode is
slater's dance circle back in the day he
decides to strut his stuff and show
kelly that his moves are better than
zach's they were definitely better than
zax
and do you hear this song playing at the
max
it's the same song that zach inserted
subliminal messages into in the episode
the zac tapes
again not cool zach
and who can forget the threads
in the original series there was always
a set of twins walking the halls of
bayside wearing matching outfits
and that's still the case in the new
season as we see matt chatting up a pair
of twins whose clothes are identical
and that's what i call a double date
let's just hope they at least have their
own interests and hobbies when mack
offers daisy some caffeine pills to stay
awake jesse swoops in to save the day
are those caffeine pills this is a
reference to jesse's song an episode
where jessie gets addicted to caffeine
pills an episode all saved by the bell
fans remember sure those pills seem like
an easy fix
at first they're so exciting and then it
gets even more exciting
but after that it gets so scary and in
the end you ruin your girl group shot at
a recording contract what
this is what growth looks like
while jessie warns daisy about the pills
she sports a headband that serves as a
wing to her high school look another
episode filled with nostalgia is
rockumentary
recognize this song friends forever
that's because it's from everyone's
favorite band zac
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
attacking my
it friends singing
jealousy warning we all remember kelly's
classic bayside sweatshirt right let's
be real we all wanted one
but the nostalgia in this scene goes
beyond the sweatshirt we all wish we had
kelly actually mentions a handful of
events from the og series listen close i
mean i i told you that story back in
high school when he sold poison face
cream or the time he made that calendar
of us in our bathing suits and didn't
get our permission or that time he
almost had screech dissected by the
government
no you didn't tell me any of that
oh really
oh
in episode 10 slater apologizes for
always telling jesse to calm down when
they went to bayside this is such a
sweet moment between the two and shows
how the show
and slater have grown
to top it off jesse calls slater a
sexist pig to which he responds with
my baby
even though they've grown up some things
never change
are you two guys fighting again
that's what we do best
well would you look at that the bell is
ringing and we have to go but there are
more easter eggs you just have to find
them that's right we're giving you a
homework assignment stream the entire
series now on peacock and tell us what
you find in the comments
[Applause]
[Music]
you